la espera es insoportable no muy lejos
de la frontera con ucrania las
autoridades polacas envían un autobús
tras otro lleno de refugiados las
familias vuelven a unirse
vivir
[Música]
otros están tomando el autobús de
regreso en sentido contrario
me voy a ucrania a pelear solo
[Aplausos]
los guardias fronterizos polacos dicen
que 200.000 personas ya han cruzado
desde ucrania y han sido recibidos con
los brazos abiertos en la estación de
tren los voluntarios reparten bolsas de
bebidas comida ropa y otros artículos de
primera necesidad
[Música]
tenía muchas ganas de ayudar a we went
shopping and así que fue de compras y
compre algunas cosas para la gente
por tipo es la misma historia de
solidaridad en hungría donde han llegado
más de 70.000 refugiados los húngaros se
han apresurado a llegar a la frontera
para ofrecer comida caliente alojamiento
gratuito y viajes a budapest hungría y
polonia han eximido a los ucranianos de
sus estrictos requisitos de asilo
mientras tanto las colas para salir de
ucrania parecen interminables la unión
europea dice que la guerra podría
desplazar a 7 millones de personas